because of longtime traditions and just
was just was part of intellectual life
in in Russian Empire and so big writers
great writers they were playing chess
and so this was privileged and part of
top society top top society people and
then after evolution new power they they
saw in chess the tool of bringing
knowledge and education because it see
it was easy it was cheap and if we
recall the time when revolution has
happened so most of educated people and
top top top society people they left the
country and so a new power should should
work out something to to make new new
intelligence and new intellectual people
and so they believe that with the help
of chess they could do it and especially
it's very cheap compared to any other
things I don't talk to them about sport
but about other subjects and Sciences
and that's why it was supported and even
during civil war when we had civil war
in 1920 first championship of Soviet
Russia took place and later literally it
became part of education system before
the World War two and after all just
became national team like you have here
in America you have visible and so
Russia had just
you